welcome to game time live at the finals
presented by YouTube TV great to have
you with us here for our post game
coverage the Hall of Famers Shaquille
O'Neal Grant Hill Charles Barkley I'm
Matt winter good to have you with us I
thought Denver won this in the first
quarter Jack yeah they came out with
great energy Joker what can you say
about them you know he's
sat here and watched him very impressive
passing scoring leadership and he's a
true definition of letting the game come
to you Charles and myself and Grant
sometimes we will go get it but you know
the first five six minutes he probably
didn't even take a shot he's making sure
right here he's not gonna let you get
away with this mismatch right there
we're going that visit you two little we
read that play way before it happened
right here you know most guys are
special they're the number one option
they're going to get it I want to score
but you know what I'm gonna look for my
teammates I'm gonna create opportunities
for them and this is a true definition
of a great player not only does he make
himself look good makes everybody else
look good and I don't know if he's a
past person or shoot first big man but
he definitely plays the game the right
way and listen he was super impressive
to watch this is the New Age Era of the
big man he can go inside he can outside
he can pass it's starting to break but
again if you're a smaller Defender and
your teammates are you know going
against smaller Defender he's not going
to let you get away there he's going to
make the right play every time right
here a little soft double take your time
pass right here little pick and roll
slip to pick and roll get it back he
could have scored that but you know what
Jeff Green cutting under the basket made
a great play this guy is super
impressive as a big man and I'm happy I
got to see him a lot he identified every
mismatch in that opening quarter he
found his bigger teammates guarded by
smaller Heat players and they punish
them 20-6 in the pain in that opening
quarter while jokic was handing out six
assists and 46 points overall in the
paint but early on you said attacking
and the thing on that clip that Shaq
showed us the guys were all moving
cutting moving without the basketball
because they know that jokic will find
them he's dominating the game in the
first half with those passes that Shaq
talked about and not scoring yeah and
that's the danger of him he can beat you
with the you know with scoring but
really dangerous there with the past and
setting the tone early Aaron Gordon take
a little bit pullback where you find the
mismatch and you attack you mean
actually the smart basketball you know
it's so easy to play in today's NBA game
but two things really bother me uh
number one these guys are so impatient
they never try to take advantage of
these the mismatch they just jack up
threes and the second thing is these
guards they say if you're a great Garden
they had to put one of these big guys on
you you should score every single time
if you're an elite guard a center or a
big guy should not be able to guard you
right but these guys are so impatient
today and I love Shaq's pitchers because
in Grant said it's old school I'm like I
didn't realize it was old school and
they put a little ass dude on a big old
dude that's just good basketball seems
more like remedial school to me like a
bad idea right where's the stream uh and
it's so funny we can't say what we used
to say uh but now we say mouse in the
house mouse in the house and dude
everybody know oh where's the mismatch
at least we've been screaming people
like I have my fans coming me man why
y'all scream Mouse all the time to do
when you put a little guy on a big guy
that's what it's like jokix dominated
this first half while taking one
official shot attempt and that was in
the final minute of the second quarter
he's a great player again fun to watch
you know John Wooden said about the true
definition of a great player is the one
that gets his teammates involved and
Grant makes a great point when you cut
like that and he finds you you know
they're gonna keep doing that they're
gonna keep cutting and keep cutting and
keep moving that's why this team is very
hard to defend and then when he decides
to score he can score at will and this
is so it's so old school reminds me of
Rick Smith's a little sabonis he's not
giving you four or five moves contact
get you out the way and go to the you
know little faith way or the Lord you
gotta go to Michael Moore okay I want to
say something what Grant said earlier
beautiful to watch